it is june 29 2022 and you're watching
the code report well it's that time of
the week again a fresh new web framework
has been born and i know exactly what
you're
[ __ ] do thinking anymore it's name is
fresh and it's dripping like literally
the logo is dripping but more
importantly it has some awesome features
it ships zero javascript to the browser
by default has no build step during
development and is based on the island's
architecture which i'll explain in
detail in just a minute fresh is a full
stack framework for server-side
rendering like ruby on rails or laravel
but you write your apps in typescript
because it's built on top of dino which
if you don't know is a javascript
runtime alternative to node.js dino was
created by ryan dull the same guy who
created node.js because he wasn't
totally happy with the way things turned
out the first time and it's my fault and
i'm very sorry and unfortunately it's
impossible to undo now it is officially
pronounced dino and not deno as i messed
up in this video but the benefit of
using it for a web framework is that you
get first class typescript support out
of the box in addition you can build and
deploy your app without a build step
while most javascript developers are
bragging about increasing build times by
10 percent dino developers just don't
even have a build step fresh can be
deployed to the edge instantly with dino
deploy the simplicity here is really
awesome one drawback though is that dino
has a much smaller ecosystem when
compared to node.js and not all npm
packages are compatible the most
interesting thing about fresh though is
that it's based on the island's
architecture which is also known as
partial hydration the idea is that you
build a website using a javascript
framework in this case fresh uses preact
for the ui but instead of sending
javascript code to the browser you
render everything to static html on the
server that means by default the only
thing the end user gets is a static html
page which is much faster for the
browser to load and render in many cases
though a website will need more
interactivity than just static html and
that's where islands come in but first
respect to jason miller who's the first
person to describe the island's
architecture and also the creator of the
pre-act framework and a bunch of other
stuff that you're probably using for
free right now when a website needs more
interactivity than static html it can
opt into javascript on individual
components the way that works in fresh
is that any component kept in the
islands directory will also ship
javascript to the browser all other
components will be rendered as static
html this may look familiar if you've
ever used astro which also takes a
similar approach but one drawback to be
aware of is that every page is server
side rendered it's not like next js
where the client side router takes over
after the initial page load then renders
everything else client-side it can be
harder to implement libraries like
firebase authentication because you'll
have to move your authentication logic
to the server in other words preserving
state from one route to the next could
get tricky it's a lot more like a
traditional web app as opposed to a
modern single page application when
building an app with fresh i really like
the simplicity you have routes based on
the file system and can easily create
strongly typed apis it's also based on
web standards like the fetch api which
allows it to be deployed to edge
functions that produce extremely fast
response times anywhere in the world
another cool thing worth mentioning is
that it uses remix style form
submissions when submitting a regular
html form you can write typescript code
that will handle that form submission
directly in the component file for that
page overall you've got a lot of cool
stuff in a very simple package now you
can take your side project that's 90
done throw it in the garbage and give it
a fresh start this has been the code
report thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one